heading out with the Mexican Navy into a
225 square kilometer no fishing Zone to
protect the most endangered marine
mammal in the world here it is the
Bakita the planet's smallest pawpoise
which only lives in the Gulf of
California
there are only between 10 and 13 left
the Navy and the seahorse a ship of the
Sea Shepherd the marine conservation
organization are patrolling the waters
they live in to try and save them
they may they finally had some good news
a survey that showed in the last two
years the bakitas numbers had stayed
stable
Barbara Taylor who's been fighting to
save the backington for 30 years LED it
it's important globally to have a good
example of what can be done to save
these species that are very savable if
we just change our sip our fishing
practices
the pools and the vacita's decline is
credited mainly to the Mexican Navy
putting down a maze of concrete blocks
with hooks to snag any Gill Nets in the
no fishing Zone called the zero
tolerance area or ZTA this has a this
has held a lot for making the CTA free
of net so we have no illegal fishing
panga inside the CTA we have no Nets in
the CTA so basically it's a win Gill
Nets are used by fishermen to catch
other fish and shrimps but they can trap
the Bakita too
perhaps 10 to 13 back heaters doesn't
sound like a lot but most people
expected it to be wiped out all together
by now and it's a big deal that it's so
far escaped Extinction
seahorse Captain Alejandro even got the
chance to see one
I have been here in Sea shipper for a
year and a half trying to do something
for protective Akira like to make it
happen to make sure that it's gonna be
alive and it's gonna survive and when
you realize that it's still over there
by your own eyes and you have been doing
this for some signing Fields very
amazing
but while the government and NGO Focus
has been on saving the Bakita the
fishermen who depend on these waters for
their livelihood feel they've been
forgotten Lorenzo Garcia says they
support the no fishing Zone but they've
been forbidden to use Gill Nets not just
there but around it and the Nets they
are allowed to use don't work as well
neither the government nor the ngos have
really looked at the social side of this
they say we're going to do this just
thinking of themselves and the vaquita
not about the fishing community and
asking what are those families going to
live on
now the Mexican governments announced
that the no fishing area will be
enlarged a victory for the scientists A
further Lifeline for the Bakita and a
problem for fishermen who say they're
already struggling
John Holman Al Jazeera San Felipe Mexico